this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development well good afternoon everyone
and welcome to the Thursday October 11
2012 session in our series on Green
Transportation in Asia and uh today
we're going to take a very large kind of
policy overview and look at some new
technologies and new uh government
funded programs that are coming out of
Japan before I introduce our speaker
today though couple of business items if
you are registering for credit and you
were not here last week please be sure
and fill out the survey form and give it
to
Tiffany in the back and uh if you were
here last week and have signed up for
the course for credit your name is most
likely going to be on an attendance
sheet that will be passed out sometime
during the session today make sure you
sign it because that is the record of
your attendance if we don't get a record
of your attendance you don't get credit
for the attendance and as you know
that's one of the requirements for
getting credit so uh please make sure
you sign the attendance sheet um I'd
also you know on behalf of the us Asia
technology management center which
produces this series like to thank the
Allan Miner foundation for additional
financial support of this series we had
a great session last week including the
standing around talking part afterward
and that kind of thing is very much uh
due to the kind financial support from
our sponsor uh so please enjoy the time
after our formal talk today as well as
uh during this session I was also really
happy to see some of the first written
comments coming in from this session
this past week uh people are doing a
great job picking out interesting things
to comment back to me and that makes me
feel good because it shows that you're
you know engaged in the session so uh
look forward to seeing those remember
comments are due two weeks within the
first two weeks after the date of the
session so all of the comments from last
week will have to be turned in by next
Thursday this time okay um today it's a
real pleasure to welcome back a Stanford
Alum to uh come and speak with us uh Mr
Osamu onoda was an MBA got his MBA from
The Graduate School of Business here at
Stanford and uh he is now a senior
official in this organization called Neo
the new energy and Industrial technology
development organization which is
a government related
organization in Japan that administers
funding and projects most of which come
from the ministry of economy trade and
Industry uh and it's in charge of new
R&D projects in some ways Netto in Japan
is sort of corresponds to an
organization like DARPA in the US but of
course economy trade and industry has
nothing to do directly with defense
unlike DARPA but uh funding a lot of big
projects in areas that range from energy
Energy Efficiency and smart grid to
biotech information technology and
nanotchnology
um Mr onetta is the chief representative
of the Silicon Valley office of nto uh
since
2010 and as such he represents Netto all
across the Western us and as we're going
to hear today Netto is involved in
supporting smart grid projects in New
Mexico and also in Maui uh as well as uh
other kinds of projects between the US
and U Japan before uh his nto position
uh onam was with Mei and he was
responsible for international issues and
energy conservation and renewable energy
development including us Japan
cooperation in clean energy and in the
smart grid uh he's also been involved in
several multinational uh initiatives in
this area so let me turn over the
microphone to uh Mr onella thanks very
much for coming today thank you very
much thank you very much for uh having
me so uh so my name is OS NOA from Neo I
uh Dr Dash did an excellent uh
presentation of my uh credentials so
I'll I'll pass on that uh it's a
pleasure to be back here uh in Stanford
to uh give a a short talk on Green
Transportation policies and examples
from Japan uh so here I have set out the
agenda first I I start off with an
introduction next I'll take an overview
about the transportation sector and
reduction of CO2 in Japan uh next I'll
talk a little bit about EVs and EV
policy and uh after that I'll talk also
about the potential of fuel sell
vehicles and then uh I'll touch upon a
little bit on n's project that we are
doing in Hawaii as it uh relates to uh
Transportation first uh energy is a
global challenge I probably uh there's
no need really to go through all of this
but uh uh this is a uh upper left side
is a slide uh uh from uh uh IA it talks
about how much uh CO2 has to be reduced
uh in order to uh uh uh meet the uh uh
CO2 reduction goals to reach What's
called the Blue map which is uh to try
to stabilize uh
uh uh uh climate change at about two
Centigrade degrees uh above current
levels and this is uh how much we uh CO2
we have to reduce uh we have to reduce a
whole lot uh before 2050 and most of
that is through Renewables and also
Energy Efficiency and if you look at
this part here the blue part here a lot
of that actually will be uh have to be
done through Transportation you can see
also CCS carbon uh uh SE in Caron
sequestering and also nuclear uh in
there um now uh in order to reach that
uh IA has also done a lot of work in
terms of uh what kind of investments
will be necessary it doesn't uh talk
directly about the CO2 emissions in uh
or reductions in the transportation
sector but you have to uh uh uh do 35
plant of CCS 20 plants or 30 plants of
nuclear we have to uh invest this much
in wind onshore uh we have to build 55
concentrated solar power plants Etc so
we have this much of uh investment to do
now this blue part is what we have to do
and this brown part is what we have been
doing so actually uh looking into the
investment that is necessary actually
there's a huge amount of investment that
has to be done between now and
2050 uh if we look at the global clean
energy Market uh according to Bloomberg
new energy Finance actually from the
level of 53 billion in 2004 it has been
increasing to 260 billion in 2011 so
actually even now at this meager level
we have been already increased the
global clean energy Market by a huge
amount and that shows how much
investment potential there is in this
market uh this is a slide which I often
use mainly because it tells you
something that is uh common sense you
divide CO2 emissions and by energ energ
Supply multiply by energy Supply you get
the same thing you divide by GDP and you
multiply by GDP you get the same thing
so the right hand side and the left hand
side is the same now what we want to do
is to reduce CO2 emissions but at the
same time not decrease GDP but rather
increase it or keep it now in order to
do that you have
to reduce these two so this is CO2
emissions over energy Supply which means
non fossilization of energy Supply so
you have to uh promote nuclear energy
renewable energy Etc you have to also uh
uh decrease this energy Supply over GDP
that is Energy Efficiency so this is
promotion of Energy Efficiency as a
whole so you have to decrease these two
to reduce CO2 emissions and increase GDP
at the same time so this is very common
sense but this is something that we have
to
do one of the things that uh we are
thinking in Japan and actually around
the globe is this concept of smart
Community I think you've heard the word
smart grid uh in a lot of places maybe
uh for those people who have been
involved in the energy area but this is
a a concept that we are trying to
promote uh in Neo and we actually um
established a new Department called the
smart Community Department uh mainly for
that purpose if you look at the power
sector in the past it's kind of you have
a main grid which has centralized power
and sending it to various uses like
buildings Like Houses like uh factories
Etc uh so that's the kind of old grid
that we have been uh having uh one uh
concept that we have is a smart grid
which is to try and make the grid
smarter to facilitate more renewable
energy that is wind power and mega solar
which kind of uh fluctuates depending on
on nature and in order to uh kind of
match that uh we uh need to uh make the
grid smarter so that it can do uh uh uh
uh Power flow in both ways uh especially
in the case of Japan because of our um
uh uh kind of uh energy situation and uh
land situation we have to have a lot
more uh uh uh emphasis on rooftop solers
and distributed generation because we
don't we just don't have the uh wide
lands in U uh in
US one thing that is uh uh so
one one uh point of difference between
the smart Community concept and the
smart grid concept is one how to use
Heat at the same time actually when you
generate electricity you emit a lot of
uh heat and uh one of the things is to
how to and uh uh if you look at the
power uh plant right now they uh waste
up to about uh 60% or 70% of the heat
when they are generating electricity so
one of the keys is to do co co
generation and try to use the heat as
effectively as possible that's one
difference between just a smart grid and
a smart Community the second point is to
uh include the aspect of Transportation
so uh how to link Transportation
effectively into the grid is uh also a
very interesting uh uh part of this uh
especially as you know EVS are actually
have batteries in them and these
batteries actually can be used to help
the grid as opposed to hindering it so
those are kind of two uh major parts
that of the smart
Community let me uh next look at the
energy consumption situation in
Japan uh this uh maps from 1973 to about
2007 which is not most recent
unfortunately but uh you get the general
idea so GDP has increased between 1973
to 2007 2.4 times so we have been able
to increase uh GDP uh having economic
growth now if you look at the energy uh
uh uh growth in that period uh in
million kiloliters in crude oil
equivalent it has been increasing uh uh
you know uh having an increasing Trend
in uh uh accordance with the GDP growth
but if you look at the industrial sector
commercial residential sector and
transportation sector you see that the
industrial sector has been a very very
good pupil in uh
uh in maintaining uh keeping uh the uh
energy use in that sector down so if you
look at between 1973 and 2007 it has
been flat which is actually a you know a
remarkable you know when you think of
the fact that GDP has been growing by
2.4 times but if you look at the
commercial residential sector and the
transportation sector it has been
growing so that's the general kind of uh
Trend that uh uh you have have in these
sectors uh the industrial sector because
it's relatively small well uh you have
to deal with relatively few number of
people it's much much easier to uh
reduce uh uh CO2 consumption than in the
transportation sector and the commercial
residential sector that is not to say
that and uh if you look at the
transportation sector it actually uses
about a quarter of the energy use so uh
in order to uh reduce CO2 emissions by a
huge amount you have to uh uh tackle the
transportation sector let us look at uh
take a closer look at transport uh the
left hand upper side uh transport energy
use has stabilized uh the total from
about 2,000 and it's actually uh
reducing a little bit share of Passenger
transport has been increasing from 52%
in 1990 to 62% and cargo has been uh is
is is like this if you look uh divide
these to in two sectors in passenger
transport the share of all
automobiles uh uh Railway and air is
stable automobiles in Japan is about 2/3
but this shows actually that in order to
reduce uh energy consumption in this
Transportation sector you do have to uh
tackle uh uh trans uh passenger
transport especially
automobiles in cargo transport uh share
of automobile truck has increased from
50% to
63% that mainly is uh kind of a factor
of uh people want to have more
convenience you know if you go to Japan
uh it's actually very very convenient
because you can have deliveries uh uh on
time and uh a little bit different from
UPS and uh the uh cargo delivery system
in US you can actually uh say oh between
10:00 a.m. and 11:00 a.m. so it's you
know people have been uh uh going from
just morning to uh uh to a very very
specify time uh uh uh uh
very specified times and that actually
increases the amount of energy that is
used probably to Del make deliveries but
that's a matter of consumer
preferences uh this is uh an except from
the uh me's long-term energy plan that
was uh made in 2010 and this looked at
uh what the consumption of uh energy in
the transportation sector has to be uh
in order to uh meet uh uh Japan's CO2
reduction goals at that time now uh
having said that I'll uh give a Proviso
in that the uh me long-term energy plan
uh uh has been is in the uh uh is in the
process of revision mainly because of uh
the uh tsunami earthquake and the change
in the uh situation uh uh related to
energy according to the 2030 uh energy
plan uh by m at that time
uh a lot of the CO2 reduction was
supposed to be done through the increase
of nuclear power uh you know from 30% to
actually 50% of our electricity was
supposed to be uh provided through
nuclear now as you know uh with
Fukushima that is no longer possible and
prob they are saying either 0% or 15% or
25% as the case may be and so uh and I
do not foresee any possibility for
actually increasing the uh dependence on
nuclear uh so uh that is short hand for
saying we are either not going to be
able to meet our CO2 reduction goals or
uh we will have to do something much
more drastic in terms of renewable
energy Etc but uh so that's uh uh uh
kind of uh some uh notes on that but uh
the plan uh was to reduce from 245
million tons of CO2 to 154%
so 37% reduction uh compared to 2007 and
the ways to reduce that was first
diffusion and Fu efficiency Improvement
of Next Generation
automobiles uh diffusion is kind of
trying to increase the deployment of uh
biofuels although biofuels is not a
really uh good uh option for Japan
mainly because we do not have the big
farming uh kind of uh that uh the US has
in terms of corn diesel or or or what
have you uh the third is uh uh to do
this through model shift that is
increasing the share of railroad and
Coastal shipping and uh for Mid and
longdistance uh Transportation so those
were the kind of options that were being
considered and uh that was one of the
things that uh was uh those are the
things that are to be used in the
transportation sector now based on that
and uh uh and next uh I'll talk about
what what are Next Generation Vehicles
so Next Generation Vehicles as you know
you have biofuel cars natural gas
vehicles clean diesel vehicles hybrid
cars electric vehicles fuel cell
Vehicles plug-in hybrids and hydrogen
Vehicles so those are kind of some of
the options that are on the table um in
terms of uh Next Generation vehical
options I'll touch upon a few of them
and some of the characteristics of each
one first is the hybrid so hybrid as of
the end of 2010 we had 1.4 million
vehicles in Japan uh and they are
actually the main state of what would be
termed Next Generation vehicles uh they
can reduce CO2 emissions up to 50%
compared to current vehicles uh but
challenges include cost and Improvement
of batteries and as I'll talk about it
little bit later uh we have been uh
putting in place uh subsidies to try and
promote uh the changing over of uh the
fleet uh to Prius and there are numerous
others that I won't touch upon uh EVS uh
electric vehicle as of end of 2011 there
were 18,000 vehicles in Japan and the
Nissan Leaf although the IM by
Mitsubishi was kind of the first EV
commercial EV on the market there's been
a really large increase with the Nissan
Leaf uh they can reduce uh CO2 emissions
uh by 40% or even down to 0% uh
depending on what kind of fuel you use
or electricity you use if you use
photovoltaic panels to completely fuel
the uh uh the the EV then you can go
down to 0% but the normal thing is you
know right now it's about 40% or
something like that uh there's uh one of
the keys as I will touch up later is the
need for charging infrastructure and
there are possible range problems at the
moment uh in terms of the current EVS on
the market except for maybe the uh Tesla
which actually cost a lot more and then
uh you know uh some examples is the
Nissan Leaf Tesla Mish me
Etc plin hybrid is kind
of kind of a good option that's in the
middle of the hybrid and EVS in short
range it can be used as an EV although
the E uh plug and hybrid EVS right now
have a relatively small range so uh
unless you have a very very short range
it's going to uh eat into uh the um
Hybrid part and in Long Range maybe used
as a hybrid so it does not have the
range anxiety prob that an EV has uh
there's also less need for charging
infrastructure which is uh very very
good uh the plugin Pi Chevy Volt Plug-In
Honda Fit are some examples of that and
then finally uh uh fuel sell vehicles
they actually have great potential in
reducing CO2 emissions and most large
vehicle manufacturers are are developing
these vehicles and are eager to try and
uh commercialize those uh 2015 has been
set as the target date for
commercialization uh by a lot of
companies uh again this actually has a
great need for infrastru infrastructure
and uh uh the cost of each vehicle is
actually a bigger problem than EVs and
also the cost of the infrastructure is
also a big uh problem uh there are a
number of uh uh uh fuel sell vehicles uh
that are coming maybe on the market in
2015 or
so this is the diffusion or deployment
projections and targets that were uh
kind of calculated by the ministry of
economy trade and Industry in a uh
what's called Next Generation vehicle
strategy 2010 so that kind of was this
uh uh uh considered more or less in
tandem with the uh 2030 energy plan so
it kind of tries to show the left hand
side is if the private sector is left on
its own they were projecting that this
will be the case so in 2020 uh
conventional Vehicles will um continue
to be about 80% of the the um uh market
and the Next Generation Vehicles will be
less than 20% uh and in 2030 it will uh
increase marginally but relatively uh
timidly uh EVs and plugin hybrids will
be about 5 to 10% of the market maybe
and uh will be increasing to this amount
so that was kind of the projections that
they had quick question is that
production b or is that how yeah that's
that's on an annual annual basis so
annual kind of deployment basis okay and
this is kind of like the government
targets that uh were set in order to
meet at least to a certain extent the
targets CO2 reduction targets that we
had and of course here we we're trying
to increase the Next Generation vehicle
to up to 50% of the market and uh EVS to
uh and plug-in hybrids from the 5 to 10%
to to 15 to 20% so in order to do this
well you need to uh uh have a lot more
things put into place and so that's I
think one of the Logics that was used uh
uh to uh put in place the uh uh
relatively robust uh uh subsidies in
this area yes uh what is
CDV CDV clean diesel vehicle so I guess
uh uh diesel actually has um um uh
better fuel efficiency than uh uh than
uh normal gasoline vehicles and clean
diesel diesel is considered to be one of
the options uh in terms of trying to
reduce CO2 emissions of course diesel
will continue to emit CO2 but you know
it's uh more efficient yes I just want
what the share you said it was 1.4
million hybrids and what share of the
market I I'll talk on that uh in the
next
slide so the number of Next Generation
vehicles have rapidly increased to 1.5
million cars as I said partly uh hybrid
and uh uh very very small minuscule
amount EVS so if you look at uh but this
is still about 2% of the general Fleet
so it's it's still very very small it's
been increasing at this pace but as you
see most of them have been the green
part which is the hybrid so you have a
little bit of natural gas a minuscule
part of a electric vehicle
and almost zero fuel vehicles of course
you know except for demonstrations and
if you look at e have increased but even
if you look at here EVS are still only
1.6% of the Next Generation vehicle
Market in 2010 and I'll move on to my uh
discussions on EVS but having said that
uh EVS have been uh increasing quite uh
rapidly so EV sales are reaching over
about 1,000 monthly we've stopped around
U the newest data is around uh January
2012 unfortunately but uh I I've heard
that it's relatively above 1,000
although not as kind of um how do you
say rapid as uh we hoped it will go so
uh the Nissan Leaf has uh made a
measurable impact in terms of the uh
rate of expansion of electric vehicles
in terms of monthly sales so about a,
monthly that's when the they uh kind of
uh started uh uh I think this is the
result of the subsidy I think
yeah so basic the direction towards
diffusion of EVS uh the cost uh creating
initial demand and reducing cost by
producing economies of scale so as you
uh increase the economies of scale
you'll be able to decrease cost that
actually is uh something uh that we have
been doing in the area of photo volak uh
I won't uh dwell on that uh this time uh
but uh in Japan we had a relatively
robust uh photovoltaic subsidies in
place and that was actually one of the
things that uh allowed the uh initial
reduction of the cost of photovoltaic
panels and after a certain amount and
you get a certain amount of uh price uh
uh then you start to increase the market
quite
rapidly so maybe it's just me but I'm
very unfamiliar with these subsidies can
can you go into more details
I will go on that later yes uh second uh
performance So currently as you know EV
is still have a a range kind of um uh
limitation I'll go into that later but
so in order to change that you have to
increase the battery performance uh also
as I said infrastructure is uh very very
key in order to um promote uh increase
the deployment of EVs and have uh
consumers more more comfortable with the
idea of having EVs and from that point
of view uh one of the things that the
government has been doing is what called
EV and plug-in hybrid uh vehicle towns
so uh the government actually cooperates
with the uh local community so they
started off with
these uh kind of fuk Kyo Nagasaki nigata
alori Tokyo kanaga with these
prefectures to cooperate together to uh
one increase the infrastructure of P of
EVs and at the same time try and get
these prefectures to buy a certain
number of EVS to Kickstart the market
and uh also to increase the kind of
consumer awareness of uh EVS so that's
uh what we've been doing and then this
has been uh increasing to those uh
prefectures uh in
red now if you look at uh the uh uh uh
various uh uh EVS plugin hybrids on the
road uh uh on the left hand side you can
see that the EVP plug-in hybrids towns
have uh 66% of the total and if you look
at the quick Chargers in use again uh
these towns uh constitute about 63% of
the total uh
yes you know the numbers still look
small but this really only started in
school year 2011 so maybe from
summertime of 2010 or so and remember
plug-in hybrids have really just hit the
market they're you know the only the
newest Priuses are plugin right yeah and
uh well uh you go back Chargers are
they the which
level IO that yeah uh I probably should
St we're doing in terms of charging
infrastructure there are What's called
the normal Chargers and the quick
Chargers so normal Chargers uh these are
like 100 volt 200 volt and they take
about in the case of 100 volt 14 hours
to fully charge in the case of a 200
volt uh it takes 7 hours the quick
charge it takes approximately 30 minutes
to fully charge but in order to get a
half charge it's a little bit less than
15 minutes so those are kind of uh allow
a person to charge their car outside of
their homes now having said that in
order to have uh uh to help out the grid
you want to minimize the amount of quick
charging and you want to uh maximize the
amount of normal charging so you don't
want to put too much emphasis on the
quick charge but having said that as I
said when you think of the anxiety
problems uh uh that EVS can have it's
necessary to have a certain number of
Quick Chargers to uh uh allow the
consumer to be happy I'll pass on this
one and uh and well in terms of
installation these private charging
stations they can have in the house
Condominium office building uh Etc and
actually the condominium part is the
most difficult part I
think uh in terms of uh EV tourism uh
that's one of the things that uh it's
been doing in the plin hybrid and hybrid
towns uh that is try to increase the
awareness of EVs and also to increase
the kind of uh initial demand for EVS
and uh so this is an example I took from
Kyoto you can look at that later on if
you want uh in terms of policy for the
diffusion of EVS so uh there are three
uh uh Parts one is to try to increase
the efficiency of the batteries so the
department at Med they've put in place
26 million per year to try to enhance
accelerate the development of uh
Advanced lithium Eon batteries they've
also tried to put in 43 million per year
to uh uh post lithium batteries and also
as I said because infrastructure is such
a big part uh they put in place uh 555
million to subsidize half of the Charger
price and also incentives for purchasing
EV plugin hybrid EVS uh which provides
half of the difference between the
prices of EV plugin hybrid and their
base vehicle so they put in place pretty
big amount of subsidies mainly because
uh this whole issue is kind of a chicken
and egg problem unless you have
infrastructure uh people will not buy
EVS unless there are EVS people will not
put in place infrastructure so uh this
is kind of a way to try and
um uh get around that problem of chicken
and egg uh I'll pass on these two uh
well and you can see some of the uh kind
of details regarding uh the uh charging
infrastructure Etc uh now in terms of EV
charging infrastructure so the Target
that uh the government has set before
2020 is to have 2 million normal charges
which is pretty big and also have 5,000
quick charges around
Japan uh of course EV should basically
be charged at uh by the normal chargers
at night that is the B basic uh premise
but a certain number of charges need to
be uh in place in order to provide a
safety net and so uh the um how do you
say logic is in order to uh prepare the
market one just have to uh provide uh
some of some one uh background
information so that people can uh be uh
uh preparing for that and also uh
provide subsidies in order to Kickstart
the
market now uh uh as I said uh quick in
terms of quick charges 5,000 is the
target yet uh but now as of now there
are over 1,300 fast Chargers in Japan
and 4,800 normal Chargers available to
the uh public so they've been increasing
quite rapidly in Japan now uh I actually
had a couple of slides that the Nissan
was using in one of their conferences oh
okay just curious when you say available
to the public I mean there's some that
aren't available to the public of course
uh if you have a normal charger at home
that's not going to be available to you
to the public if you have a charger
inside an apartment building that is
used only for those people living in the
apartment that would be a yes a normal
charger but it would not be a public
charger do do you know what the number
is I think you said by 2020 2 million
normal Chargers which includes both
public and non right so do you know what
the current number is when you add in
nonu
charges I not sure I don't have that
number with me
sorry so uh yeah uh going back to my
presentation uh so uh I actually had a
slide by
Nissan which I wanted to use but they
wouldn't let me so uh I cannot use it
but uh as you know uh currently uh uh uh
a lot of the vehicles you know the uh
most advanced Vehicles they all have
like some kind of GPS capability so they
know actually how much you've driven uh
what have you
and actually that came in very very
handy when there was the earthquake and
tsunami because using that that data
they were able to see uh where the
vehicles were being driven and you can
therefore deduce which roads are open or
not and which roads are not open cannot
be driven and so that actually uh helped
in the uh Transportation right after the
earthquake and tsunami but uh and so uh
they are able to see H which Road s are
being driven by EVs and how much U I'll
go back to you uh so if you look at the
uh the map of Japan right now actually
everywhere except for Hokkaido and uh
tohoku is almost a mesh so you can see
uh that EES are being driven all over
now how often they go from here to here
I don't know but they are probably
going uh a longer distance than they are
in the US let me let me go to the next
slide if you look at uh us I think there
are about 30 uh uh uh quick Chargers in
the US right now uh mainly for some
standard reasons that I will touch upon
later these are the number of char uh of
U quick charges in the US now if you
look at the same map and you map the um
uh roads that EVS have been driven of
course there is a line between Los
Angeles and you know there are some
people who have driven between here and
here but what you see is small round
clusters except for a little bit and you
see a a thin line between between Los
Angeles and uh uh San Diego and and uh
San Francisco but all of these are a
little small clusters it's not a network
yet and the main reason that that is the
case is because there are no quick
charges and it will take literally
as I said if you try to charge a a car
with a quick charger normal charger it
takes what uh 17 hours to do that or or
eight 10 hours as the case may be so uh
you just unless you are an adventurer
trying to make a point you will not do
that so that is the situation in uh
Japan and us and there's a second slide
also which kind of was interesting is
that if you uh map out the
people uh uh or how much each EV uh uh
user uses on an average basis actually
us EV users drive more or drive longer
distances than the Japanese EV user
which makes sense because of the uh
wider area but the interesting thing is
if you look at the Avid users the people
who use a lot uh uh the EVS then at
around the uh 100 kilometer level which
is the you know uh a turning point of
whether you uh use a quick charger or
not it actually flips the other way
around so uh the heavy users of EVS in
Japan actually drive them a lot more up
to 200 kilometers Etc so that's a big
difference in uh Japan and us uh EV
Market which actually is a result of the
uh relative lack of quick charges up to
now in the US market please I'm sorry
the previous Slide the the Chargers in
in Japan uh there's a certain color
coding I'm just wondering what the color
coding means good question I was
thinking of looking that looking that up
but I forgot to do that uh if you look
at the chademo uh kind of homepage uh
you will be able to get this map so uh
you should be able to uh uh uh figure
that out but I think if I remember
correctly it's the green ones are where
you just have one charger and the others
are kind of where you have multiple
Chargers I think I think that was the
the thing but I have not uh checked it
out sorry I I knew that this was
coming so these are the uh kind of
chademo uh compatible EVS that are
already uh uh coming out uh actually if
you look at the EVS it's not just
Japanese vehicle but you have stren and
pujo and a number of other companies
that are coming up as well this quick
charger issue is actually a result of uh
how do you say standardization or lack
of standardization coordination between
Japan us and EU unfortunately uh so
there's one uh
U uh uh uh the chimo uh uh kind of
standard was one that started off in
Japan and it's a charger that looks like
this it if you look at uh globally there
has been an increase in Cho uh uh uh
charges around the globe but uh in uh us
there's What's called the U SAA
standards which are look somewhat like
like this that's the Society of
Automotive Engineers I think yes and uh
in EU they have a combo connector like
this and they weren't really able to uh
kind of uh agree on a common standard uh
and so that's the main reason that uh uh
you know uh there has been some
reluctance I think uh to uh uh put in
place Cho connectors at the moment but
uh the thing is in the case of the SAE
standard it was only agreed upon I think
this year they did agree on a standard
about the format but there are no cars
that use the SAE connector uh charging
uh standard on the market yet and uh
from what I've heard uh maybe uh
sometime next year so this is not only
the shape and kind of size of the socket
it has to do whether it's AC or DC uh
somewhat yes uh so uh uh uh yes um it
does have a little bit to do with that
yes but uh I think uh the main issue was
that the chatmo was a kind of um uh it
it's it's a separate connector that has
to be used for normal charging and uh uh
quick charging as opposed to this
connector and this connector which
actually uses just one so you have one
connector there's a normal charging and
uh quick charging and you know uh you
can use either uh using just one
connector in the case of the chadore you
have to have one uh normal charging
connection and the as separate so you
know it's a little bit of a difference
in philosophy and also in terms of the
speed of uh the charging uh the chimo uh
connector as I said uh takes somewhat
more time than the sa and uh
uh uh combo connector but having said
that one thing that is of interest is
actually if you look at the quick
charging uh quick charger
installations uh the uh power box
enclosure there's actually a lot of
commonality between the Chargers and
according to the discussions that I have
had with uh charging station U
manufacturers actually you are able to
flip over uh a uh uh Cho um uh quick
charger to and retrofit it to uh meet
other um standards and so actually uh uh
probably uh the standards issue is
becoming no longer an issue in terms of
delaying the uh kind of uh installation
of quick
Chargers so conclusion um what we have
to consider now are trying to uh put an
emphasis on users uh you know I think
there are uh uh a number of a good
number of EV users already in California
which actually are feeling a little bit
somewhat stranded in terms of lack of
infrastructure and so how to try to
ensure the uh competive compatibility of
devices going to the future but you know
trying to uh put in place uh the
necessary infrastructure for them and uh
constructive cooperation between the
various manufacturers are going to be
necessary going into the future
uh next I'll go on to fuel cell Vehicles
I've already run out of time or no
you're okay I'm okay we'll take the time
okay so uh industry trends for fuel cell
vehicles and H2 station so as I said
fuel cell vehicles are another kind of a
vehicle that is of great interest now uh
EVS are good for kind of uh shorter
holes but they have to carry battery so
you don't want to put a huge amount of
battery to to whole cargo Etc and so
actually uh fuel sell vehicles are said
to be good for especially cargo related
applications and if you look at the
automobile manufacturers as I said they
are all uh be it BMW be it uh Toyota be
it Honda Nissan Etc they are actually
all trying to launch F sell vehicles and
so uh they are saying that they will
start commercialization in 2015 now in
order to uh Kickstart that what we want
to try to do is is to make an expressway
between the four major kind of um
population centers in Japan Tokyo Nagoya
Osaka and fukoka and hydrogen fuel
suppliers on the other hand they think
uh this might be a good business and so
they are uh aiming to construct
approximately 100 hydrogen refueling
stations by
2015 and hopefully they will work
together to create a new
market uh oops so this is kind of a
commercialization scenario which is U uh
being considered so between 2011 and
2015 this is the market demonstration uh
period 2015 as I said is the start of
the sales of the uh uh fuel sale
vehicles and early commercialization up
to 2025 and then 2025 onwards will be
the full
commercialization and so uh what they
want to do is they want to try to reach
approximately 1,000 hydrogen student uh
stations and approximately 2 million
fuel cell Vehicles by
2025 in whether that is possible in a
period of 10 years from 2015 that's a a
pretty uh aggressive Target but who
knows uh we've had a lot of iones in the
past few
years now for the first stage a number
of hydrogen stations are being uh put in
place for a demonstration of the
Technologies so uh you can see that
there are a number of fuel cell stations
especially in this uh relatively uh big
uh Corridor as I showed you and
uh there are this I'll say a few words
on this 35 megapascal and 70 megapascal
Etc this is the U pressure at which the
uh uh uh vehicles are are refueled the
uh 35 megapascal which is the lower kind
of pressure is actually easier to do uh
and that is the kind of perent uh
pressure that is being used right now
but the problem is that lower the
pressure the less gas you can put in and
if you have 70 megapascal much much
higher uh pressure you are able to put
in more fuel into the vehicle and if you
try to have uh kind of uh equivalent uh
range uh between the fuel cell truck and
the normal truck you need to have a
higher um pressure that is the the key
point
there uh a number of demonstrations are
put being put in place to prepare for
this uh um demonstration uh like welcome
home taxi service airport taxi those are
kind of like uh you know because the
fuel cell vehicle is still a very very
expensive vehicle you need to try to do
it uh in terms of uh uh in an orderly
manner but you can't really uh do it for
uh normal houses Etc it's too expensive
a vehicle to to to do that so these are
some applications that are being
explored they're also putting in place
airport limousines rampas Etc to do uh
Fleet
demonstrations uh the number of hydrogen
stations in Japan as of 2011 was uh uh
16 increasing to 19 in 2012 and
hopefully uh more going into the future
so uh I think California is in a kind of
a similar situation as as this in terms
of
deployment so uh with that we're also
going to uh uh some uh uh uh discussion
about n's projects in the area of
Transportation uh we uh Neo actually as
uh Dr Dash said is doing a number of uh
projects in uh us and across the world
uh one is uh in the state of New Mexico
which is a kind of a smart grid SL micro
grid demon demonstration that we are
doing Albuquerque and in Los aramos uh
the other is in Maui Island which is in
the state of Hawaii uh which I will uh
go into greater detail we also are doing
a number of projects in France in uh
China and in
Spain uh this uh project in Maui is
called the Japan us Island grid project
uh it's uh if you look at Hawaii it's an
isolated island and so it has its uh
peculiar challenges and opportunities uh
in terms of challenge because it's a
small uh Island uh you want uh it you it
takes a cost a lot to bring oil and
gasoline uh from uh outside and so if
you look at if you've been to uh
traveling in in Hawaii sight scene you
can see that you get sticker shock when
you go to the gas station every time on
the other hand uh uh it actually has uh
benefits as well one is actually Maui
Island and the Hawaiian Islands are are
blessed in renewable energy in terms of
uh solar and the wind
Etc another thing which is good in terms
of EV is electric vehicle is that
actually there is less room for range
anxiety if you are in Maui you can only
go so long before you hit an EV charging
station if you if you get
a good amount of uh good number of EV
charging stations and you can do it
relatively small uh fewer and so uh
there are pluses and minuses so and uh
actually uh uh Hawaii has this uh Hawaii
clean energy goals which is to reduce
its uh carbon emissions by uh
70% uh uh by
2030 uh partly through renewable energy
and partly through Energy Efficiency and
so they have pretty agressive goals and
so
uh the state of Hawaii and Neo were
discussing how we can uh do a project
together and we signed anou in uh
November
20111 to do uh this uh project uh n will
be covering uh$ 37 million us for this
project sorry I actually talked about a
lot of what's in this slide but uh one
of the things uh that uh large scale
renewable energy introduction will uh uh
uh cause in terms of problems in Hawaii
is uh there might be Surplus power in
the nighttime because uh in Hawaii they
use a lot of energy in the daytime but
in the night time you have relatively uh
less use and actually you have a lot of
wind coming in so there are issues of
surplus power uh I don't know if you
know much about the power uh uh uh area
but electricity has to be balanced in
terms of demand and Supply real time in
order to uh have electricity stable uh
quality electricity
and so actually if you go to a power
company like pg& d they are ramping up
demand uh Supply you know starting up
new gas fired stations Etc in order to
uh uh follow the load uh so there are
cases of surplus power also uh because
uh and fre uh in terms of frequency
frequency is the measure that you can
see in terms of demand and Supply if
there's too much demand and too little
Supply the frequency starts to deviate
from 60 HZ to become longer and longer
and longer uh if you uh imagine uh uh 10
people cycling to uh try to generate
electricity for a a light bulb over
there now if you increase the load the
generators have to push a lot harder uh
in order to do that and so uh frequency
starts to go down and down and down
because they have to uh uh uh uh roll a
little bit harder and so uh but the
problem with the power grid is that uh
IF frequency starts to go down some of
the generators starts to uh go off when
uh because uh to uh to uh to protect
itself uh from uh breaking down uh if
you have a gas engine that's uh uh that
has a certain capability if the
frequency goes down to a certain level
they just go offline and so that's one
of the reasons that you have uh large
scale blackouts uh uh in um in various
areas and so you have these issues that
are kind of concomittant with renewable
energy introduction and the uh and at
the same time actually the more PV
systems and the more EV you have on the
grid uh it can also have a lot of
problems in the distribution line uh so
this is kind of an islandwide problem
and this is a kind of very local problem
so you have these two issues and you
have to figure out how to solve both of
them at the same time and so what we are
doing in uh in uh Mai island is to put
in place an islandwide smart EV system
to try to coordinate the charging of the
EVS so that they do not coincide at the
same time uh for example if I drive an
EV back home I plug in the EV at 6 p.m.
everybody does that at 6 p.m. you have a
blackout probably if you have a a good
number of EVS so what we want to do is
to try and stagger the uh charging
between six p.m. and you know 7: a.m. or
8:00 a.m. as the case may be uh so that
the uh load will not be uh coming on at
the same
time at the same time uh you have these
local problems as I said if you have a
certain number of EVS in that uh uh kind
of uh P toop Transformer or the feeder
and they all charge at the same time
this will blow up and so you don't want
to have that either so uh you want to
try to coordinate this and this this at
the same time and in order to do that uh
you may need to have more intelligence
in the grid and so that uh uh we're
putting in place an islandwide EV uh
charging system and kind of a localized
uh control system in uh an area called
The kii District in uh uh in ha in Maui
Island so uh we are also considering
trying to uh in uh um have uh and uh to
expand that to include vehicle to the
home and vehicle to the grid which is
actually something that is uh been that
is being commercialized in Japan
especially the vehicle to home part as
uh there is a a bigger how do you say
anxiety towards uh energy Supply uh
after the earthquake and
tsunami so with that uh that concludes
my uh presentation I'm sorry I've taken
a little bit more time than I should
have we have some time for Q&A thank you
very much for very interesting
so let me lead off with a quick question
uh after the disaster in 2011 and Japan
may be shifting away from nuclear power
toward more Renewables is that going to
impact the mission of Netto in terms of
how Transportation fits into your
overall policy picture um yes I I I do
think so I mean uh in terms of the
hydrogen fuel cell uh vehicle program I
think uh MTI has been putting in place a
lot more emphasis on that area also the
EV uh part as well I think there's been
a very big push to since 20 even since
2011 so I think uh that is uh something
that we be yeah okay thanks for for
letting me go first question's open um
uh let me see let me I I know that in
Japan you've had subsidies recently
towards HDs MH uh and are those the same
as for the EVS no uh the EVS are
different
they more and and just if you know like
what are the subties for hybrids and
what effect have they have because
they're kind of interesting from a
subsid point of view since normally
subsid to early adopters and hybrids are
kind of past that in Japan I'm sorry I
don't have the figures with me right now
actually there's one interesting
difference that I'd like to mention you
know here in California one of the
things that promoted use of hybrids was
being able to use the the the uh Carol
lanes and unaware of anything like that
in Japan or any kind of reduction in
freeway tolls as a result of using next
there is as you say I think the main
reason for that is because actually cars
are not used that much for commute
especially in Tokyo or the large urban
areas and so it is less of a kind of an
incentive I mean um of
course uh places I I know of that re
where
uh cars are used extensively for
communities like Okinawa or you know uh
areas Regal cities Regional cities yes
but for large population centers I don't
think it's um you know they are not
being used for commute purposes yeah
okay so yeah thanks uh yeah I'm
interested in these Quick Charge
stations um it seems actually like kind
of a a misnomer to me because they still
take 15 minutes right which is
considerably longer than stopping at a
gas station yeah but that's not six
hours but it's a really awkward amount
of time like if you're on your way home
from work you don't necessarily want to
stop for 15 minutes and if you're like
you can't really do anything else with
that time it seems because it's not long
enough so like I would almost rather get
to work plug my car in at work and then
be good for the drive home yeah uh
definitely I think uh the uh premise uh
of the quick charger is not to be used
in normal use and so the uh normal use
is between the the house and the the
commute is you have a a charger at home
and you have a charger at the workplace
and that is the main kind of uh mode of
charging now the problem
uh a typical problem is for example if
you are having a a car in San Francisco
and you have a appoint an appointment in
San Jose and I I I I was talking with
this person who was uh doing that and uh
uh a lady was visiting this person in in
San Jose and she called him and said oh
I have an EV is there a a charger in
your uh office and he says no we don't
have enough charger in the office and so
she could not take the uh EV to that
office and so she decided to use her
second car you know is her husband hard
car what have you now that person was
saying that that was a sign that EES are
too early for the market which I don't
really agree with because if you had
that charger normal charger in the
office uh in in in that building that
person would have been able to come and
just charge get a a small amount of you
know uh uh uh addition and probably have
been able to uh drive back if you have
an hour meeting or 2our meeting you just
have a little bit of top off now that is
the main model but having said that
there might be a case oh but if you were
able to go to San Jose and you had that
appointment and you had a quick charger
you could just go to the quick charger
and charge a little bit now you don't
you may not need the full charge you may
just need to charge up to 15 uh up to
you know a certain amount now uh the if
you look at the um uh quick charging uh
station kind of deployment in the in
Japan they are typically done uh in in
front of convenience store stores now uh
they think that that's a way of getting
you know consumers into their shop now
15 minutes you can use 15 minutes inside
the uh convenience store uh look at
browse to some magazines Etc and
hopefully as they think you know buy a
few things so uh I think it really
depends on you
know uh on if you if the quick Chargers
are put in place at the right locations
I think they uh definitely can serve as
a kind of uh you know an increase in
kind of uh or decrease in anxiety can we
switch over to here for a
question yeah my question is about the
batteries uh in Japan for the a lot of
EVS are they using lium battery or there
some other batteries they are still
using lithium batteries uh mainly uh
from what I understand and uh but as I
said because the um there there are some
limits to the uh uh uh effectiveness of
lithium on batteries uh that's the main
reason they are trying to take both
routes in terms of one trying to improve
the existing lithium Eon batteries and
trying to figure out if uh the the next
generation of uh after lithium
batteries there a lot of issues in China
in terms of battery consist
in the when they try to promote the
electrical bus I don't know if there's a
similar consistency issues in Japan I
have of course battery bus is a lot
bigger than than than the cars the I
think your example is mostly for the
small uh medium size car or small car
mhm I I'm not aware of such problems
sorry
yeah yeah okay there's a a new
initiative called uh drug and plug by
Walgreen they're going to be I think
they have 1,200 stores and they're going
to be installing charge systems and I
was wondering if that is a possibility
for Japan too because is are there uh
drug store or commun not commun store
but drug store chain so as I said a lot
of the retail store chains actually have
been putting in place uh quick Chargers
and and normal Chargers mainly because
they think that it is a way of getting
customers into their shop uh and you
know it's like uh uh to use an old
example in the old days uh shops used to
have salt in front of their uh in their
shops to get horses to come and eat the
salt and uh uh because of that the
Japanese shops still put salt in front
of their uh restaurants Etc to try and
get it's it's you know it's it's a it's
a mythical thing of a sorts but but you
know it's it's a way of trying to get
customers to uh come to their their
shops but anyway so charot I think let's
go back back okay
back
there they don't have good studies of
what's been the increase overall to the
use of electricity on on in fan as EVS
have increased in use and all the quick
charging all the stations how much has
that increased the need or the demand in
the overall Grid in megawatts or
gigawatts I don't have that uh right now
but in terms of the number of EVS right
now I mean I don't think it's a it's a
it's a measurable impact on the grid as
as of now
even of the you know of the 1.5 million
next Generation Vehicles almost all of
them are hybrids that are not even
plugin hybrids right and so the EVS are
still less than 100,000
yeah yeah it's somewhere around so uh
they have not come to the the the kind
of extent yet where they will have an
effect on the
grid uh please so you mentioned the Next
Generation Vehicles were selling at a
thousand a month
yeah that's uh that's a two percentage
of 2% of the vehicles are Next
Generation what are the sales of non
next generation of just regular gas per
month
uh sorry I don't have that with me right
now but uh one can calculate probably
from this yes I'm sorry I don't have it
off the top yeah I don't I don't have
that
either um let me see okay
please so I was I was curious about post
uh post e like once the car is okay so
assuming that you hit Market saturation
and I think you mentioned you wanted uh
Japan was aiming for something like 20%
of of like all users that have EVS what
do you is there any kind of
recycling any recycling part set up at
all for disposal of the batteries um is
there anything um there are a lot of
demonstrations actually taking being
taken place right now in terms of trying
to use EV batteries for Second Use uh
now what what I mean by that is that
uh when you increase the amount of
Renewables into the grid uh you are
going to have balance of uh balance
Supply demand problems and so batteries
are one way of trying to uh balance the
supply and demand real time uh now
batteries are still quite expensive now
having said that if you can use the EV
batteries second hand and use them on
the grid then you can probably decree
increase the uh cost of the uh uh
batteries that you are putting into the
grid as well as
perhaps reducing the cost of the EV
initial cost of the EV because you'll be
able to sell the batteries now that does
have several problems because if you
have EV batteries that have been used at
different to different extents you have
batteries that have you know maybe 70%
of their capacity left they might you
might have some that have 50% of their
capacity left Etc and
so it's going to be an issue about how
you can kind of coordinate the various
batteries in a meaningful way without
costing too much uh now that kind of
demonstration or test is being conducted
uh uh in Japan and also in the US I
believe I forget where but but that is
being considered yes so the idea is that
the battery will Outlast the vehicle
people will change their vehicles every
3 years or so and so the batteries will
still be good I mean the thing is uh if
you uh decrease the range from 100 you
know kilm to 70 km or 50 km you know it
becomes really unusable as a car but
that's still a battery that can be used
if you have enough of of them there so
you know but so so that's kind of I
think uh the idea behind that
okay on um yeah first of all I'm a owner
of the Nissan Le and that you said that
there's two issues for the ab and one is
a range and another one is U
infrastructure I think this is true in
the US but I think that there are two
more issues in Japan one is the cost of
electricity I pay about 7 to
1010 per month for my mean Le um
compared with I paid $150 per month for
gas carard and the second issue is that
people don't have a garage and I have a
charger station in my home but the
people doesn't have a people cannot have
a a charging station and most of people
has a know a rent a parking space near
to their apartment so there are two
issues in Japan that is there any idea
Japan is thinking uh I think uh what you
say is very true in terms of actually in
uh in Europe as well because they uh
Park their cars not NE necessarily
inside the garage but uh outside in many
cases and uh it really probably will
become an issue of you know uh how to
have a public charging infrastructure
outside in the in the street for example
in the case of Paris or or something
like that or in the case of a home or
outside parking rot you have to do
charging outside uh you know you can
probably do that but you know you just
have to to um how do you say put in
place different kind of equipment to
allow you know if anyone in Japan is
doing some sort of a subsidy program for
public parking garages to have a certain
number of spaces for EV charging
or uh not sure but uh you know they they
they are also able to apply for the
subsidy as I said you can get one one
half of the cost of uh charging uh uh
infrastructure installation uh be
subsidized and so by using that uh I'm
you know uh you can you can you can do
that okay I saw a question over yeah
okay uh I was just wonder do you know if
there's any data of how much the quick
Chargers are actually being used because
sometimes there's discussion of that
they're necessary but that people
actually don't really need them because
they charge most of the time at home or
at work uh I I'm sure there must be data
but uh sorry I have not looked at that
data but what you say is correct in that
a lot of the quick Chargers are not used
that um how do you say uh that much uh
and that is how it should be in a sense
uh in terms of trying to decrease the uh
increase in demand of electricity in the
daytime uh you want to have them charged
at night time when you have relatively
cheaper uh electricity rates and when
you have a uh relatively abundant
electricity but uh as you say a lot of
the charging quick quick charging
infrastructure is not used as much and
so uh it creates a big business model uh
problem for those companies who put in
place a lot of quick Chargers thinking
that there might be a lot of charging
people but uh even when the EVS increase
the amount of charging does not increase
that much so but but uh at least in
terms of uh qualitative evidence what
you say is correct
please or or actually I see three in one
order or I curious about technology
charging and battery if if you use super
super high technology with charging the
battery how how long does it take uh to
charge the FL even it's cost it me it is
not cost
effective I'm not exactly sure um The
Cho takes about 30 minutes as I said but
uh uh there are some technologies like
one by um uh
uh oh I forget the name of the company
but uh that does it in a much shorter
time like 15 minutes but but uh but from
what I've
heard uh it may have negative effect on
the battery and so uh you
know it really is a is an issue of you
know what kind of effect it will have on
the
battery so uh and and even in the in the
case of the chadal standard you know
what they do is they charge rapidly
relatively rapidly at the beginning and
then as it uh becomes near the full
charge they kind of slow down the
charging so at the end they kind of
trickle charge uh near to um the uh they
they reduce the voltage and so uh I
think you know it
and one I think the Tesla kind of
charger tries to do have a a much much
bigger faster kind of charge but uh I
think that uh that kind of takes a toll
in terms of the cost of the charging
infrastructure Etc so you know it's it's
a balance between those two I think so I
saw two other hands
Marty yeah I'd like to ask you about the
the uh source of electrity in relation
to the EV in 20
2025 was it when the uh
commercialization starts uh do you have
any idea of how much percent of the
electricity comes from the renewable
energy that is anybody's guess I think
in terms of uh that's what they are
trying to uh discuss right now uh in
terms of what the energy uh uh
um how do you say con you know the uh
the percentage will be in
2030 now uh I would guess it's somewhere
around 20% or or something like that as
they are thinking about right now and
they are going to be if they reduce
nuclear what they would probably do is
increase
gas um uh now it really depends on on on
how fast we can uh deploy renewable
energy at relatively uh how you say uh
cost effective manner but uh you know
it's it's really anybody's case I think
reting evv is to reduce the CO2 level or
whatever environmental issues yes so if
you depend on the uh fossil fuel does
not make much sense Marty think about it
right now EVS are such a tiny percentage
of the total number of vehicles if you
get up to 12% of the vehicles on the
road being EV then you've matched the
current percentage of renewable energy
that's being used in Japan right the
transportation sector is almost all
fossil fuel so any increase you can use
in the number of EVS is going to go with
the national average and as long as the
national average is better than 100%
fossil fuel right then you've made an
improvement and it really depends on
what kind of energy uh uh when the
energy is being made or produced and
when it is being consumed now if you uh
if you look at the energy situation in
Japan uh roughly speaking uh nighttime
electricity is more abundant than uh
daytime electricity and so if the EVS
are going to be charged in the night
time it still makes a lot of sense now
if but that is based on the premise that
there is AB nuclear no nuclear is a base
load and gas is kind of uh more uh but
but even then you know if you look at
the demand structure it's it's still the
case that the daytime electricity is
more kind of more in demand than the
nighttime so as in so long as EV is
charge at night it probably makes a lot
of sense to increase the EV fet now it
also if um you you are able to increase
the amount of renewable energy going
into the future it kind of allows for
more smoother transition now uh fossile
fuels uh probably will last for 50 years
even maybe 100 years who knows 150 years
I don't know but they will have to be
weeded out at some point in time and
probably electricity is the uh most um
kind of
fungible uh fuel source and if we have
100% fossile based transportation and if
you have a 30% fossile based uh
Transportation it's going to be a big
difference because not going to be able
to change from here to there in in in in
in five years we had one more question
that I saw somewhere around in here yeah
go ahead um so one on one of the slides
you mentioned that using an electric
vehicle in Japan after you account for
the the the CO2 emissions of the energy
production it would be about 40%
reduction in CO2 emissions right but
there was also something next to it that
said uh 0% using photo voltaics is that
a plan it sounds like it be really hard
to implement oh yeah yeah it's not
really plan it's it's it's it's just a
matter of fact that if you uh use
electricity you can reduce CO2 emissions
by anywhere between 0% and 40% now the
reason for the 40% is that uh in the
case of combustion uh oil combustion um
uh fossil based uh automob mobiles you
are actually emitting a lot of
heat at that time and uh although the uh
gas engines are gasoline engines in a
car are quite fuel efficient than they
used to be they are still less efficient
than the most efficient gas turbines
generating electricity so uh as a
combination of that you are able to by
using EVs and the current fuel
composition in in in Japan you are able
to reduce uh CO2 emissions by 40% but of
course or 2 40% of the current vehicle
but uh uh on the other hand if you are
able ble to change over to all nuclear
and all renewable en uh renewable energy
for example or something like that which
uh uh probably needs to be the case in
200 years from now let's pick a number
then or 300 years as the case may be
then it will be uh
0% okay I think that it's time for us to
call an end of this session we've got
some refreshments outside hope you'll
stay around and talk for a little bit
please talk with our speaker outside so
we can clear this room thanks everybody
thanks for
coming